I'M JESSE WATTERS WITH
KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE,
JUAN WILLIAMS, DANA PERINO, AND
GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
IT'S NOT A GOOD DAY TO BE
NANCY PELOSI.
THE DEMOCRATIC LEADER COMING
UNDER FIRE FOR TWO COMMENTS MADE
JUST TODAY, AS LAWMAKERS FROM
BOTH PARTIES TRY TO WORK
COMPLAINING THAT NEGOTIATIONS
WERE BEING LED BY FIVE WHITE
GUYS.
>> Reporter: WHEN WILL WE KNOW
YOU HAVE A DEAL?
>> STAY TUNED.
[LAUGHS]
ARE THEY GOING TO OPEN UP A
COME AND DO THIS.
>> Jesse: THE NUMBER TWO
DEMOCRAT IN THE HOUSE, STENY
THAT WASN'T A LOVE
TRICKLE -- IF THAT WASN'T
ENOUGH, SHE CONTINUED WITH THIS.
>> AS FAR AS THE BONUS VERSUS
THE CRUMBS THEY ARE GIVING TO
WORKERS, IT'S SO PATHETIC.
>> Jesse: WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT, MS. PELOSI, I'M SURE
$1,000 IS MORE THAN CRUMBS TO
THE WORKING CLASS YOU PRETEND TO
FIGHT FOR.
GUYS, THE HAMBURGER CHAIN.
THERE IS A CLEAR RACIAL
IMPLICATION.
HELPFUL OR NOT?
>> NOT HELPFUL.
SHE GOT ONE LAUGH.
>> Jesse: A LATE LAUGH.
>> Kimberly: A DELAYED LAUGH
TRACK.
TAKE SHOTS AND WHITE MEN.
IS THAT THE RIGHT THING TO DO?
NOT NANCY.
I'M SAYING YOU HEAR PEOPLE
PUTTING DOWN, DISPARAGING WHITE
MAN, WHATEVER PROTESTS ARE GOING
ON.
I DON'T KNOW WHY SHE HAD TO
BRING THAT UP.
BECAUSE I DON'T LIKE ITS
REZONING -- IT DOESN'T SERVE ANY
PURPOSE OR HER DISTRICT.
>> Jesse: LEAVE THE WHITE MEN
ALONE, JUAN.
>> Juan: SOMETIMES YOU THINK
I'VE ENTERED INTO AN ALTERNATIVE
UNIVERSE.
FIRST OF ALL, IT WAS A POOR JOKE
FIRST OF ALL, IT WAS A POOR JOK
JOKE.
IT GOT TAKEN BY PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO CRITICIZE HER AS BEING
RACIALLY LOADED.
SHE WAS MAKING A JOKE ABOUT THE
FIVE GUYS HAMBURGER CHAIN, AS
KIMBERLY SAID.
SECONDLY, WHAT SHE'S TALKING
ABOUT IS A LACK OF DIVERSITY,
SPECIFICALLY THE LACK OF ANYBODY
WITH ANY HISPANIC BACKGROUND
INVOLVED IN THESE NEGOTIATIONS.
NOBODY, FOR EXAMPLE, THE
TODAY THE MEETING BREAKS UP
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANYBODY IN THE
MEETING.
THE PEOPLE INVOLVED, THE FOUR
WHITE GUYS PLUS GENERAL KELLY,
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF, THEY
THROUGH THEY WERE SENSITIVE TO
THE ISSUES NANCY PELOSI BROUGHT
UP.
>> Greg: IF THERE WERE FIVE
BLACK MEN THERE, LET'S SAY, FROM
THE CONGRESSIONAL BLACK CAUCUS
AND SHE SAID IT LOOKS LIKE WE
BECAUSE SHE SAID FIVE WHITE GUYS
GUYS.
SHE SAID --
>> Juan: NOBODY WITH ANY
BACKGROUND INVOLVED IN ANY --
>> Greg: IT'S OKAY FOR
LIBERALS TO INJECT RACE AND
IDENTITY INTO ANYTHING BUT IF
ANYBODY MADE SIMILAR JOKE FROM A
REPUBLICAN SIDE, GOD KNOWS THE
AMOUNT --
>> Juan: YOU ARE TRYING TO SAY
THERE IS HYPOCRISY.
I AM SAYING TO YOU I THINK
>> Greg: AND BECAUSE THEY ARE
WHITE, THEY ARE INCAPABLE OF
ACTUALLY GOVERNING OR DOING
SOMETHING GOOD.
>> Juan: COME ON.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
IS MADE UP OF NONFEMALE WHITES.
>> Greg: YOU FORGOT THE WORD
EVIL IN THERE.
IT PROVES TO ME THAT LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS ARE EXEMPT FROM THEIR
OWN MORAL HIGH GROUND.
I THINK NANCY WAS MAKING A JOKE
BUT TO INJECT RACE INTO IT.
THEY ARE ALLOWED TO BE RACIST,
SEXIST, AND HOMOPHOBIC BECAUSE
THEIR HEART IS IN THE RIGHT
PLACE, RIGHT?
YOU HAVE CHELSEA HANDLER DOING
SOMETHING GENERALLY GHOULISH TO
LINDSEY GRAHAM BECAUSE SHE
BELIEVES HER HEART IS IN THE
RIGHT PLACE.
SO THEY ARE USING THE PHONY
MORAL HIGH GROUND TO ALLOW THEM
$1,000 AS CRUMBS AND HE'S A
BILLIONAIRE.
IT'S AMAZING TO ME THAT WE CAN
SAY IT'S OKAY THERE BUT NOT
THERE.
I'M FINE WITH EVERYTHING.
>> Jesse: DO YOU HAVE TO BE
SENSITIVE TO THE COMPLEXION OF
ANY OF THE GROUP WHEN YOU WERE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE IF YOU ARE
DOING SOMETHING ON IMMIGRATION?
DID THERE HAVE TO BE A HISPANIC
THERE OR DID IT NOT CROSS YOUR
MIND?
>> Dana: IT WASN'T DIFFICULT
TO HAVE DIVERSITY IN THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION.
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
DIVERSE, EVEN MORE SO THAN
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
IT WASN'T DIFFICULT.
A LOT OF TEXANS.
>> Jesse: DO YOU THINK THEY
SHOULD'VE HAD A HISPANIC
REPUBLICAN IN THAT GROUP?
>> Dana: I THINK BOB
MENENDEZ'S VOICE WAS A GOOD ONE
AND PART ONE.
THE SPLIT AND THE DEMOCRATS IS
INTERESTING FROM A POLITICAL
STANDPOINT.
THEY ARE SENSITIVE TO IT AND
THAT'S MY STENY HOYER, WHO IS
THE NUMBER TWO IN THE HOUSE
UNDER PELOSI, WHOA, WAIT, THAT'S
THE THING IS, THE ANNOUNCEMENT
COMES OUT TODAY THAT THERE IS A
DEAL BUT SOMEBODY SAYS IT'S A
DEAL.
TO GO.
SO THE STAKES ARE HIGH.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THE
LEFT IS TRYING TO DO AND NOT
ARTFULLY NECESSARILY FROM
NANCY PELOSI'S PART, TO SAY, SHE
KNOWS THERE'S A SPLIT IN HER
CAUCUS AND SHE HAS TO FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO THE FAR LEFT TO BELIEVE
SHE'S FIGHTING FOR THEM.
ACTUALLY GETTING THE DEAL AND
SELLING IT IS GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT FOR HER CAUCUS.
I THINK IF THEY REALLY WANT TO
WITH MS. PELOSI.
WE HAVE THE CRUMB GAFFE, MORE
WAS SHE WORTH $90 MILLION OR
SOMETHING?
VERY SUCCESSFUL.
HER HUSBAND IS SUCCESSFUL.
$1,000, IT'S A LOT OF MONEY,
LIKE GREG SAID, TO ANYBODY.
>> Greg: THAT IS AT LEAST ONE
HAIRCUT FOR HER.
>> Jesse: WITH A COLLAR OR NO?
>> Greg: SHE IS A
MULTIMILLIONAIRE.
HER MANSION IS INSANE, IF YOU'VE
EVER SEEN HER MANSION IN
AND SHE'S NOT EVEN A REPUBLICAN.
>> Jesse: COULD YOU RUN AN AD
>> Dana: YOU COULD.
I THINK WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO
DO A SHOW, NOT JUST TELL, THAT
THERE'S A BIG DISPARITY, THAT
THE CORPORATIONS ARE, GETTING A
SWEETHEART DEAL FROM THIS TAX
THEY ARE RAISING WAGES ARE
ADDING PATERNITY LEAVE.
WE ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
REALITY OF WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
THE ECONOMIC SIDE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
PRESIDENT OBAMA WANTED TO DO
CORPORATE TAX REFORM.
HE WANTED TO GO FROM THE 35 RATE
TO 27.
PAUL RYAN WAS AT 25.
THEY COULD NEVER GET THE DEAL.
IF THEY'D GOTTEN THE DEAL, THEY
WOULD'VE BEEN ABLE TO HAVE
>> Juan: I THINK YOU ARE
MISSING HILLARY CLINTON.
AT THIS TIME, YOU WOULD BE
BEATING UP ON HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Greg: YOU ARE MAD WHEN WE
BRING HER UP AND NOW YOU'RE MAD
WE DON'T.
>> Juan: NOW, THAT'S
DONALD TRUMP AND
KELLYANNE CONWAY.
>> Greg: WE DIDN'T BRING HER
UP, AND NOW YOU BRING HER UP.
LIBERAL FEMALE TO BEAT UP.
>> Kimberly: VERY UNFAIR.
>> Greg: YOU ARE THE.
-- YOU ARE THE
>> Juan: YOU NEED NANCY
BECAUSE YOU SAY WAIT A SECOND.
THIS BILL IS SO LOATHSOME THAT
EVEN REPUBLICANS DON'T LIKE IT.
MENTION THE CRUMBS.
NANCY PELOSI CALLED $1,000
STATEMENT, WHAT SHE SAID IS AS
COMPARED TO THE WINDFALL GOING
TO THE BIG CORPORATIONS.
>> Jesse: THEY SEE $1,000.
THAT'S GROCERY MONEY FOR A WHOLE
AMERICANS UNDERSTAND THAT THE
RICH ARE THE ONES GETTING THE
BIG BOOST.
>> Greg: EVIL RICH PEOPLE.
WALMART, WE ARE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT IT LATER.
ACCORDING TO LIBERALS IF YOU
GIVE BACK TO YOUR WORKERS,
THAT'S EVIL AND WRONG.
>> Kimberly: ALSO ANOTHER
EPISODE OF JUAN WILLIAMS IS
MOVING THE GOAL POST.
LET ME SEE FOR THE RECORD WE
DON'T SIT HERE AND DISPARAGE
WHITE LIBERAL WOMEN OR LOOK FOR
THEM TO BEAT UP ON.
WE TALK ABOUT PEOPLE BASED ON
THEIR QUALIFICATIONS AND THE
CONTENT OF THEIR STATEMENTS,
FACTS OR MISSTATEMENTS THEY
>> Jesse: AND WE BEAT UP ON
PRESIDENT OBAMA WHO IS NOT A
WHITE LIBERAL.